does cannabis prevent covid a recent
study identified that two compounds
commonly found in hemp cannabidrolic
acid and cannabidiolic acid could bind
to the coronavirus and possibly block a
crucial stage in how it infects people
both compounds appeared to hinder the
virus's ability to infect human cells in
laboratory tests the researchers found
after testing alpha and beta variants of
the coronavirus this would be
interesting you know all this time we've
been listening to the cdc we should have
been eating cbd it's while social media
had a field day with the news the
authors of the study did not actually
claim that weed can fight the virus
here's a little background on how this
came about since finding candidates for
possible drugs and treatments can be an
expensive and time time-consuming
process
researchers speed things up by testing a
large number of known compounds to see
if they produce a biological or chemical
response in line with what might be
expected in a drug treating the
condition they are trying to find
treatment for positive responses at this
stage like the cannabis compounds are
but the first of many filters the
compounds must pass and assuming all
goes well an approved drug could still
be more than a decade away we spoke with
dr michael sodegren who heads imperial
college london's medical cannabis
research group and he told forbes the
results were interesting but cautioned
the findings would need to be confirmed
in animal models and tested on humans in
clinical trials this data does not prove
cannabis compounds can prevent or cure
covet infection in humans sodogran said
and provides no evidence to support the
smoking or ingestion of cannabis
products to do the same
you